there's a new bob in town and her name
is courtney that could be
really cute courtney kardashian has a
stylish new haircut and boyfriend travis
barker approves
on saturday courtney took to instagram
to share her chin length cut wearing a
black sports bra and black bottoms for
the glam shots in the comments travis
voiced his approval the blink 182
drummer simply wrote quote you're
perfect courtney's new do also caught
the attention of some celeb pals
yeah that's me
haley bieber wrote quote so cute and
model winnie harlow said quote now
that's a bob while we have hair stylist
peter savic to thank for quartz new look
she did hint that barker gave her a trim
earlier this month after courtney shared
these couples pics to instagram her
pooch colleague sarah howard commented
quote nice cut travis barker switched to
keeping up with the kardashians star
replied quote good with his hands yeah
what is happening here these intimate
moments come after et learned how
courtney's ex scott disick feels about
their relationship i mean i think you
just gotta figure out really what's
important to you at the end of the day a
source told et last month quote scott
has gotten more used to the idea that
courtney and travis's relationship is
serious but it's not his favorite
subject of discussion it seems like you
get really upset when courtney is linked
to other guys me
yeah no um
meanwhile their little ones apparently
don't mind the coupling the source added
quote travis's kids have really taken to
courtney and vice versa with courtney's
kids they all get along great and their
families are meshing well together
that info certainly lines up with what
their fans have seen across social media
where disneyland outings and family jam
sessions are happening weekly including
this moment courtney shared last month
where daughter penelope got a master
class in drums from travis
[Music]
you